have we gotten to the point where just
we always need some kind of a war we had
Iraq we had Afghanistan we got out of
Afghanistan now it's Russia after Russia
is it going to be something else I mean
is it just a continual war machine where
we're feeding this beast that's what
Eisenhower told us it was going to be
and after Vietnam in the early 70s they
I mean there was just a slew of like
military interactions I'm very in the
dark about it's just they they're so
obfuscated in the in the Balkans uh in
like obviously Serbia Kosovo with like
in the Clinton years I remember hearing
about Serbia and Kosovo and Bosnia like
there was just bombs going on I never
knew what was what who was who I just
knew that we were involved in all this
death
um
yeah I think without without conflict
and places to blow up bombs with with
some sort of reason whether it's Faker
or real than the military industrial
complex will cease to function yes
sometimes I wonder if all this money is
being sent to Ukraine and is kind of
like to help replace the Lost revenue
from leaving Afghanistan in the Middle
East